- These are basically
the Skittles of Doritos.
(lively music)
- Okay we're about to try these
rainbow, rainbow Doritos.
- They look so happy.
- So when you donate to the
It Gets Better campaign you
get a bag of rainbow Doritos.
So we got some to try.
(lively music)
- I heard that rainbow Doritos were
making conservative groups angry.
- I'm glad I came out just so I can like,
do only gay people get to
eat these or something?
- All right lets do it.
- One, two...
- Oh they're smaller than i would have
liked to have seen.
- Oh my god, little baby.
- What's the flavor profile?
- Pretty standard
Doritos flavor and smell.
- They are the Cool Ranch.
- Thank God.
- They taste just like them.
- Thank you.
- I like 'em.
I think they're good.
- They're not bad.
It's just...
- Um hum.
- They taste like normal.
- I think they taste like Doritos.
- I'm, personally I'm a fan of
unnatural colors in food.
- If you throw them up it's kind of like
that new Snapchat filter.
It's just like bleh.
- What's disappointing
is that the powder is
not the color of the chip.
Which is really what I wanted.
- The visual representation on the bag
doesn't match what's actually in the bag.
Like this is your purple.
That's not purple.
- They're adorable and I like them.
- Is this bag of Doritos worth $10?
- It's $10?
- No, so no.
- You should donate.
- Yeah.
- Yeah like it's a great cause
and you should donate.
But you get one bag, like Doritos
can toss in like two bags.
- I think like if you are spending your
time hating on chips you have
some deep, deeper, deep set problems.
- It's 2015, if you're
not pro rainbow Doritos
you're on the wrong side of history.
So you got to get with it.
(lively music)